هذا اللقاء السوري التركي الروسي هو مؤشر
على تطويع وشيك بين انقره ودمشق لم ياتي
عن عبث فقد تم التمهيده والتحضير له مسبقا
بدءا من تغير تصريحات اردوغان تجاه نظام
الاسد مرورا بلقاءات الاستخباراتيه وانشاء
اليه ثلاثيه لتعزيز المسار الدبلوماسي بين
تركيا وروسيا وسوريا ومن ثم جاء هذا
اللقاء الاخير في موسكو رجب طيب اردوغان
الذي كان الى ما قبل نحو عام من الان يتهم
نظام الاسد بالارهاب وانه المتسبب بقتل
السوريين ودمار البلاد لكن كل ذلك تغيره
تحت عنوان لا عداء او خصام ابدي في
السياسه هكذا برر الرئيس التركي انياته
لقاء بشار الاسد في اقرب وقت ممكن
ذوبان الجليد بين اردوغان والاسد يخشاه
اكراد سوريا بشكل كبير لانهم قد يدفعون
ثمن هذا التقارب ويخسروا كل المكاسبهم
وبالتاليق فقدان نمط حياتهم الذي اكتسبوه
بشق الانفس منذ العام 2011 خصوصا وان
الهدف الرئيس لاردوغان هو افشال اي مشروع
او كيان كردي على حدود تركيا
وسيسعى جاهدا الى عدم تكرار تجربه اقليم
كردستان العراق وفقا لمسؤولين اكراد طبعا
[موسيقى]